it's no secret that the West is angry
with Russia on a whole range of issues
but the feeling here in Moscow is
decidedly mutual my guest this week is
Russia's Deputy Foreign Minister Sergei
Ryabkov what are the chances of halting
this current slide in east-west
relations or is there worse to come
[Music]
Sergei Ryabkov welcome to complete zone
the Russian government condemned in the
strongest possible terms the combined
Western attacks the recent Western
attacks on Syria but your Foreign
Ministry spokesperson says something
else is worse you said smart missiles
should be directed at terrorists not
against a legitimate government
what exactly is legitimate about the
Syrian government that gasses tortures
and murders its own people I do think
that you will agree with me that
President Assad and his government are
elected by their people the history of
their struggle against terrorism is
quite tragic and we don't even know how
the situation would unfold in terms of
if it would be possible to preserve
Syria's integral card country so you
have seen for instance a politician here
who's elected he murders and tortures
people you continue to confer legitimacy
on him I find that hard to believe I
didn't manage to answer your question
sir yet I will do it now and that is we
don't have any evidence whatsoever that
President Assad and his troops and his
forces have done anything of what you
have told us or what the collective West
has done only you haven't read the UN
reports for instance from the office of
the High Commissioner we doesn't impress
you we did read everything we have a
number of issues to criticize these
reports in terms of work of the so
called joint investigative mechanism
which the Western countries killed last
year because they didn't want to change
anything in its modus operandi they
claimed you killed yes and we claimed
they did so and you just go into our
endless gigabytes of explanations that
no one cares about everyone in the West
tends only to hear himself or herself
and disregard what
alternative view is this is one of the
most problematic trend in the overall
development of so-called Western
democracies there would be no such thing
as a democratic international order if
people don't want to hear an alternative
view so you dismissed you dismiss
everything that the UN's chief Human
Rights official has said about President
Assad he called for Syria to be referred
to the International Criminal Court last
month he said the government was guilty
of massive human rights violations and
in February 2016 a report from his
office said the Syrian government had
committed the crimes against humanity of
extermination murder rape torture and
enforced disappearances among others but
you dismiss all that Minister and I'm
curious as to why they got it all wrong
I don't know what they're talking about
look we saw in recent years a very
troubling development were what's
supposed to be what was supposed to be a
universal international tool that should
you know enforce order and move forward
agendas that are based on good faith and
compromise quest for compromise all this
has been you know developed into the
tools of geopolitical games played by
the group of Western countries led
currently by the US by the United
Kingdom by France who simply don't want
to hear anything but their own views
they're not compiled by the USA no
Britain and France we see as well we
don't dismiss anything we spent hours
and days to explain why those
conclusions and those contents of these
reports are wrong in many ways if you
have so little regard for the reports of
the United Nations why bother with the
United Nations why bother with the human
rights mechanisms when they get it so
disastrously wrong in your view why
bother we use the platforms which are
there we don't have alternatives to
we constantly present our points at all
committees of relevance in New York and
Geneva the Human Rights Council is one
of those and we will try Alice Lee and
endlessly work towards correcting what
is a very biased and politicized
approach why should it be biased and
politicized because you think they just
sit around and make these accusations up
no I think they are just so dependent on
the so-called strong guys around who in
turn don't believe in anything but their
own views I thought you were one of the
strong guys around in the United Nations
you're one of the permanent five members
of the Security Council you're one of
the strong guys who uses your visa
consider your veto consistently to
protect the Assad regime we use our veto
consistently and we'll do so also in
future to protect an international order
as set forth in the UN Charter to
protect to protect international law
which is so blatantly being breached by
the US UK France and many others who
don't care about anything but their
alliances and their you know shared
values and they say the same about your
protection of Assad I'd like perhaps you
to answer the question if you would that
Donald Trump put to Russia what kind of
nation wants to be associated with the
mass murder of innocent men women and
children can you answer that why does
Russia wish to be associated with the
country that does those things firstly I
don't believe any politician in the u.s.
is in his or her right to put this type
of questions to anyone else after what
was done by the US over years along the
lines has just described without any
explanation that's paying the what a bad
game what about the u.s. well I'm asking
about the specific for instance well we
do think that the government in Damascus
is a legitimate one which continues its
fight against terrorism and protects
it's people from scourge of geopolitical
engineering that is being played
introduced and pursued by the very same
people who now try to abuse Damascus and
Moscow in all sorts of mistakes and sins
that's very wrong I think also it's very
enlightening to see how popular is been
for a while already for people in the US
and elsewhere to talk on who is on the
right or who is on the wrong side of
history I came back to live as if the
u.s. itself is history you support the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons we do and we're one of
the most responsible and active parties
to the convention and thus we support
this organization we think it's a well
deserved Nobel Prize that this
organization received in 2013 for very
collegial and cooperative effort to
disarm Syria in terms of removal with
chemical Arsenal completely and a very
strong international involvement and
very precise and very international
control well let's talk about that
because you have misrepresented the
statements of the OPCW on Syria I'll
give you an example right
let's go back to last year khan shaykhun
right in april washington had accused
syria of using chemical weapons in
Concha Cunha and retaliated against a
Syrian air base all right your ministry
rejected those claims because it said on
August the 22nd the relevant
international organization in this case
the organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons confirmed that Syria's
chemical weapons were completely
destroyed under international
supervision all right only that wasn't
what they said was it what the OPC said
OPCW said was something different they
said Syria's declared stockpile had been
destroyed declared not the whole thing
but the declared stockpile great and
just a month before you made that
statement director General Ahmed resumed
you had
serious doubts about whether Syria had
got rid of its weapons serious that
you're not in your head you knew that I
can tell you the whole story
you knew that story I was part of it
I literally was part of it from the very
beginning from the day one when
President Putin offered to at that time
President Obama while in st. Petersburg
not to resort to military power but
start chemical disarmament in Syria and
every single day since that September
day in Petersburg I am involved into it
so I understand minister but you
pretended that the OPCW had given Syria
a clean bill of health when it was in
fact anything but clean and the OPCW
makes that point to this day they made
it again last month they still haven't
had satisfactory answers from Syria on a
number of outstanding questions well do
want me to respond to your question or
do you want to somehow look into a
broader picture of it I'd love you to
answer the question right so the answer
is the declared chemical Arsenal was
completely destroyed under stringent
international control with very material
involvement of a number of countries
Russia included us included and so on so
forth subsequently in some time the op
CW and the Technical Secretariat of the
organization started to introduce
additional questions and all points
which Syria was supposed to answer in
terms of what they were doing in the
research center in Barza how about a
number of facilities which were empty
but by that time in terms of hangars and
tunnels and so on so forth and what
about a number of munitions that were
unaccounted for the Syrian side the
Syrian government provided produced a
number of explanations and invited which
were found to be unsatisfactory
well by the OPCW and they wrote that
they said it again last month right only
to see them the US and others to rocket
and bomb down what were supposed to be
these facilities with no presence of
anything in relation to chemical weapons
whatsoever so it's you know if I've ever
seen an abnormal way to avoid and escape
HARDtalk the place where it belongs had
the platforms which were established
exactly for that purpose instead of
continuing the political process and
moving further forward to finalize the
whole file and clean up the bill so to
say the ops W kind of looked away and
looked apart from it I thought you told
me a moment ago you respected now you're
saying they're looking away right could
it be that you only accept the verdicts
of the OPCW when they accord with your
views and you're not prepared to listen
to them others could it be that they
don't listen to our views or the views
of others when we make the right points
and remind them on how the convention
should be followed if we are also
attached to the legitimate legal part of
our own behavior now I'm talking on
everyone who is member of this
convention so we completely respect the
opposite of all you we think it's highly
technical organization now it's more
worrying because it's now being as High
Commissioner on human rights at the UN
as many others as Council on human
rights they're all against it you begin
to look like a victim of very very cheap
and nasty political games of some within
NATO but also beyond NATO Minister you
keep calling for facts Russia keeps
calling for ID but when you get them and
you don't like them you dismiss them
where
standard stand where are those the facts
given by the OPCW for instance for
example let's talk about Canseco okay
the experts at OPCW had major concerns
about khan shaykhun couldn't they the
alleged use of sarin on April the 4th
2017 the event for which the Americans
retaliated let's recall that your
Defense Ministry offered at the time
what it called objective data in an
effort to prove that rebels had been to
blame a scenario that was
comprehensively rejected by the UN and
the OPCW investigators they had no
doubts about Syrian government
culpability they said in 2017 October
the leadership panel is confident that
the Syrian Arab Republic is responsible
for the release of sorry at Karen Shaco
consejo their facts based on their
knowledge their expertise based on
something that is being used more and
more in terms of a so called distance
investigation miles and dozens a miles
away from the very place of incident
through the dissemination of some staged
shooting produced by so-called white
helmets and others who completely are
playing into the hands of terrorists
without any observation of the chain of
custody of hard evidence without any
attempt to even visit Kairat airbase
from where allegedly the airplane which
dropped the bomb with alleged zerrin
flew away they never went there they
have visited anything like this and now
they try to make the very same trick in
duma fortunately we have been able to
persuade director-general assume drew
and the security department of the UN
Secretariat to let them go there and
look for their own what happened after
delaying know we didn't delay anything I
follow this hourly I know that at every
moment they were looking for green
lights for clearance
on the UN Secretariat from the
Department on diplomatic of what is
being called security in New York but
first problems we were told then there
were problems with their documents and
the press was allowed in the press was
allowed well I I'm not aware of any
problems with the documents the Syrian
government and the Russian military
police were ready to let them in from
the very first day even before the
strikes happened
nonetheless we three or four days more
were spent in an idle position first
invited and subsequently in Damascus
without any attempt to enter duma for
all sorts of reasons
oh we will never agree on this because
all this about political games and we
perceive this this way let's not talk
about a game let's talk about what your
Russia's defence spokesman Igor
konashenkov said on April the 13th he
said on television that Moscow had
evidence that the UK was involved in
organizing the event in duma we have
evidence that proves Britain was
directly involved in organising this
provocation he's right
what evidence minister a number of NGOs
who cooperate very actively with the
government of Great Britain produce how
many at least three of them starting
with white helmets and some others
including so-called Syrian Human Rights
Observatory based in London
those people are masters of producing
falsifications in terms of shooting of
something that didn't happen no no what
you said we have everybody know the
British officials are using all this as
the basis for the military attack as do
the others that's not quite the same
thing that your spokesman said is it you
said we are never Britain was directly
involved in organized organizing this
provocation how did it organize Minister
why do you believe that something
happened in
looma why do you think something at all
was there and it was not something that
was developed in computers of those
people with the involvement of the
British a first question is not evidence
is it Minister we haven't seen any
evidence on your part either on the
opposite you just throw these things out
there that we have evidence that Britain
was involved in organising this
provocation but you don't but you don't
have one scrap of evidence so you're
prepared to give we believe that there
is no credible alternative explanation
but the involvement of the British
government it's highly likely that the
British government is involved in treats
highly likely in doing that and that's
your evidence okay but we've seen you've
put forward irrefutable evidence before
haven't you
like last November when your Defense
Ministry said it had irrefutable
evidence of cooperation between US
forces and Islamic state militants and
it attached photographs apparently to
prove its point but these photographs
were completely different from what they
were billed as a fact spotted by a group
of Russian internet investigators none
of the five photos attached to your
defence ministry's posting was what they
had claimed them to be well I would be
eagerly ready to look into these photos
once again and discuss those with our
people at the Ministry of Defence
I do think that what people at the
Ministry of Defence of the Russian
Federation are producing when they are
talking on situations is number one
completely credible number two based on
facts and not on empty accusations which
are pouring on us from all sorts of
sources and number three we do so in
thorough coordination between
governmental agencies here in Moscow so
it's not without clearance and knowledge
of everyone involved that such things
are being put forward and disseminated
on the part of Russian officials they
blame the civilian employee and deleted
deleted their tweets on the subject
absolutely we should also take comments
about the poisoning of sergey and julius
gripper in england with also with a
pinch of salt you've produced an
extraordinary array of counter
accusations against britain perhaps
britain poisoned the script bells
perhaps it had abducted them perhaps it
was holding them against their will a
coordinated and well-planned campaign
you are ambassador the UN said with the
aim of discrediting and even d
legitimizing russia do you really think
that britain hasn't got better things to
do with its time i don't know that's the
question to the British side by the way
they don't answer any of the questions
which we produce and furnish to them
formally through diplomatic notes
without resorting to any microphones
dozens and dozens of those they count
four so-called scenarios that they
believe Russian government disseminates
they started with 18 then they went up
to 21 subsequently they talked here in
Moscow on 30 now they are down to 24 we
endlessly count how many explanations of
what has happened with serious [ __ ]
and his daughter is being produced from
different sources in Great Britain but
one of your two million of Rinku Glyph
who worked on the Soviet chemical
program were attacked with a compound
that he had indeed indeed but that
doesn't mean that anything like this
happened after the conclusion of the
convention and after Russia became party
to this convention no he said that he
said that a similar poison have been
used in the murder of a Russian
businessman evanka Valley D in 1995 I
went in to look into what has been
opened up in terms of documents and
files and minutes of this process by the
Russian prosecutor general a couple of
days ago
interesting parts of that story that I
mean that has been revealed but coming
back to those people who worked in
Shahani and elsewhere you must remember
that all these people were removed from
the Russian Federation after the
dissolution after the demise of the
Soviet Union with the help of the
Western governments and subsequently
they made public
all the formulas in relation to
so-called Navi chalk family to use the
word the title of this substance
introduced by the British confirmed by
the OPCW it was never confirmed biopsy W
we are right now these hours talking at
op CW on a failed attempt of the British
government to use op CW as a tool
against Russia because no confirmation
is given in this final report even in
its confidential no no not at all it
only changed has it no from the very
beginning from the outset that on they
only confirmed a formula of this crisis
but with no attribution to from where it
comes from at least 15 to 20 countries
around do have capabilities to produce
these things the British to conclude
that something like this was used
against Syrian units crippled must have
an Athlon a reference sample which no
one but themselves would develop and
synthesize so it's it's an open secret
we reject the accusation that there is
no credible explanation but I understand
you reject and you've rejected all the
points that I've raised which the West
has raised where is this relationship
going how do you find some common ground
between Eastern West Allis if you could
be very brief because we're running out
of time
well I think it's gonna get worse I
think my personal well in Russia the
foreign
policies being guideline
guided by the presidential decisions we
only introduce this in practice my
personal view is that a dual-track
approach to the West they needed on part
of Russia that is deterrence / dialogue
on issues which is in which are
interesting for Russia and it should be
based on strategic patience over time
when people recognize how long they were
in all their failed attempts to change
Russia they may move to a better
understanding of the new world alright
Sergei Ryabkov thanks very much for
being on
[Music]
you